i'm here with cigar from the glamour
team and we've been talking about how to
perfectly match your foundation to your
skin tone but also achieve something
that feels really comfortable and
something that you can wear all day
every day so we're about to try the
Rimmel match perfection foundation and
I've got a few tips on how to apply it
so we're going to start with a little
just one pump first of all not too much
foundation and it depends really you
know you might have a couple of areas on
your face that you'd like to have a
little bit more coverage you can start
there so I'm just going to use the tip
of the brush and bounce the foundation
of your skin what I love about this
foundation is that it blends super
easily okay so it's time for the next
step so we're going to talk about
brightening your dry so we're using the
match perfection concealer and
highlighter I like to take a little bit
on the back of my hand again classic
wedge sponge it's a really great way to
apply this concealer what I love about
it is that it wears for up to 13 hours
so it will keep you nice and fresh
looking underneath the eyes so let me
show you a way to really boost your base
I'm using the Rimmel natural bronzer and
a soft bonding brush and we simply sweep
it over the high point of your skin so
starting on your cheekbones and your
chin bridge of your nose even so it's
time to finish the look well I have the
color precise our lining pen and what
this will do it will just enhance your
lash line and really make your eyes
stand out sagal your eyes are looking
beautifully defined so let's finish with
lashings of volume color is mascara this
mascara is amazing if you want instant
volume it has a really handy brush that
gets really close to the roots of your
lash and this mascara actually Tinch
your eyelashes over time so you get
darker washes much
how's that look great thank you
you